Liam Payne and Cheryl Cole welcomed  their first child together  [Music]  the 23 year old one direction singer and  33 year-old Cheryl took to social media  Saturday to announce they welcomed a  healthy 7 pound 9 ounce baby boy on  Wednesday March 22nd the couple both  shared this sweet snap of Liam holding  their little one he captioned the pic in  part Wow it's a moment that I will never  forget for the rest of my life and my  favorite memory I have so far it's  amazing  the two first sparked pregnancy rumors  in November 2016  after Cheryl's bump was clearly peaking  through a curb hugging dress during an  event they attended together in London  England oh my life stood by man  congratulations to the happy couple  [Music]  you